When we solved this equation, we got x equals negative 2. What's awesome about
math is that we can know we are right. We can substitute negative 2 in for x and
check to see if the equation is true. It's like if we are seeing if the scales
are still balanced. To check to see if we are right, we take the value negative
2 and we plug it anywhere we see an x. Remember to use parentheses when
substituting values, we don't want to make mistakes with negative signs. Now
that we've plugged in negative 2 into our equation, we know that the left side
should be equal to the right side. The equation should be balanced. So, here's
your skills check. What number should go into these boxes to check the answer?
Remember, the last boxes should be equal if we've done it right.